الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي دمر مسجدا هنا
في المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه رفح جنوبيه
قطاع غزه عبر شنه عدد من الغارات الجويه
التي ادت الى تدمير هذا المسجد بشكل كامل
وتدمير منازل مجاوره كذلك ايضا ارتقاء عدد
من الشهداء وعشرات من المصابين كما
تشاهدون هنا امامكم هذا هو ركام هذا
المسجد في منطقه حي التنور شرقي مدينه رفح
جنوبي قطاع غزه كما تشاهدون هنا حجم
الضمار
والخراب الكبيرين وكان زلزال قد ضرب
المنطقه من شده هذه الغارات التي طالت هذا
المسجد ودمرت منازل مجاوره هنا في هذا
المكان وارتقى عدد من الشهداء كما نشاهد
في هذا المك المشهد امامكم سوي المسجد
بالارض تماما حتى اللحظه غير معلوم ان كان
هناك اشخاص تحت ركام هذا المسجد ام فقط من
تم انتشالهم هم فقط الشهداء عموما سيارات
الاسعاف والدفاع المدني ما تزال تعمل في
هذا المكان هنا كما نشاهد ضمار في منازل
سكنيه مجاوره لهذا المسجد وايضا هنا لو
استدارت الكاميرا الى الناحيه الاخرى ترصد
لكم حجم الضمار الكبير في منازل مجاوره
هنا وملاصق تماما للمسجد هنا نرى ايضا
جهودا من قبل طواقم الدفاع المدني التي
تحاول البحث هنا عن نجين اسفل ركام هذا ال
[موسيقى]
المسجد حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل للحرب على
قطاع غزه وجوه كثر من بينها التي تستهدف
المساجد والكنائس هاني الشاعر لقناه
الجزيره مدينه رفح